since his introduction in 1982
cannonball has been at the center of
some of the x-men's wildest
strangest and most compelling stories
and despite having one of the most
straightforward powers in comics
his history is as complicated as they
come in the early 80s the x-men were in
the dead center of a long and extremely
profitable reign
as the biggest thing in comics legendary
stories like the dark phoenix saga
and the time bending days of future past
had cemented the team as having a scope
that was
truly epic while the ongoing superhero
soap opera kept readers hooked with a
web of relationships and heartache
that ran through the stories these years
unquestionably brought some of the most
important comics in marvel's long
history but along the way
something about the x-men had been lost
as originally created by stan lee and
jack kirby in 1963
the x-men were based around a school
where teenage mutants could learn to
hone their powers between their missions
as a superhero team
by 1975 chris claremont and dave
cockrum's introduction of the all-new
or different x-men had changed sure they
had a single teenager hanging around in
the form of superhero trainee kitty
pryde
but the rest of the team were adults who
had very adult problems
like dealing with the mistakes they made
in the past or being seduced by dracula
marvel had been built on the backs of
coming-of-age teen superhero stories
thanks to characters like spider-man and
with the merry mutants of the x-men
becoming the hottest thing in the
industry
that probably seemed like a good thing
to revisit the only problem was that
uncanny x-men itself was too popular to
take a step backwards
if they were going to do a story with
teenage x-men they needed some new
mutants which is exactly what claremont
and artist bob mccloud did in the
appropriately titled marvel graphic
novel
the new mutants the setup for the new
mutants graphic novel was a simple
throwback to the early days of the x-men
mixed with the international flavor that
had made the all different teams such a
success
teenagers from across the world realized
they had mutant powers and came to
charles xavier's school for gifted
youngsters to learn how to control them
or at least most of them did sam guthrie
on the other
hand took a slightly different path to
professor x's doorstep
and it started when he was recruited to
the other side when his powers
manifested
sam was still living in the fictional
cameron county kentucky
at only 16 he dropped out of school to
work in an appalachian coal mine to
provide for his mother and nine brothers
and sisters when his father died
i thought maybe i could work the mines
with you guys unfortunately
his first day at work involved a caven
that trapped him and a co-worker named
lewis under tons of rubble
the good news was that sam was of course
a mutant and his blasting power which
propelled him through the air
inside a nigh invulnerable force field
allowed him to free himself and save
lewis in the process
the bad news the coal mine incident was
observed by donald pierce
a name that ex-fans may recognize as the
mutant-hating cyborg that the x-men had
faced off against when they took on the
hell fire club
in a twisted effort to get revenge
pierce recruited sam before xavier could
taking advantage of the otherwise decent
young man's poverty by giving him a huge
salary
of course it wasn't long before sam
guthrie had his face turned
by the end of the new mutant's graphic
novel he'd shown up at the x
mansion to join the team and when the
new mutant's ongoing series launched the
following year
he was part of the core cast he'd remain
with the team through most of its
iterations and would even become the
co-leader alongside danny moonstar
it's worth noting that sam's adventures
alongside the new mutants were weird
even by marvel standards in fact they're
weird even by x-men
standards through it all though sam's
innate friendliness and decency
remained a constant and made him one of
the characters most likely to make
friends
as they bopped around the marvel
universe when they wound up in thor's
home of asgard for instance
sam struck up a seemingly unlikely
friendship with etri the draw off
one of the smiths that forged mjolnir it
started when sam found himself
wandering around near velir the realm of
the dwarves
hearing a scream he leaped into action
to save ichiri's wife evganda from a
marauding band of trolls
led by the aptly named throughoff the
terrible cannonball won the fight
but in the process he took a spear to
the back courtesy of throth and earned
itri's respect and friendship
itri would even gift sam some high-class
magic equipment in exchange for his help
including an impenetrable suit of armor
and a magic sword
unfortunately at the end of the
adventure loki set
everything back to where it was before
stripping sam of etri's magical gifts
believe it or not a hammer-smithing
dwarf with an endless supply of magic
weapons to give out for birthday
presents
was not the most important relationship
that sam struck up during his time with
the new mutants
that honor goes to lila chaney
intergalactic rockstar
space criminal in addition to having the
best one-sentence resume of anyone in
the marvel universe
lila is an incredibly popular musician
who originally bore a suspicious
resemblance to joan jett
she's also the frequent target of
interdimensional bounty hunters
due to the fact that she's a mutant with
the power of teleportation along a
minimum distance of light years
and yes that's the minimum a world
famous musician with a side hustle
committing space crimes
might seem like an unlikely romantic
interest for the humble crew-cut
sporting son
of a kentucky coal miner still after sam
rescued lyla from a bounty hunter the
two of them struck up a relationship
that lasted for the next few years
sadly they eventually parted ways but
that's to be expected
long distance never worked what
it never worked especially when that
distance is measured in parsecs
at the dawn of the 90s the new mutants
underwent a pretty radical change
marvel's various mutant titles had only
grown more popular over the previous
decade
and they became the launching pads for
some of the biggest new names in comics
a new crop of creators had come up with
a new kind of aesthetic that would drive
their titles to record-breaking sales
in the pages of new mutants marvel
readers were introduced to superstar
artist rob liefeld
in his tenure on the title he introduced
cable in new mutants 87
and deadpool in new mutants 98 with
number 100
the series was cancelled and relaunched
as the all-new all-violent
x-force with cable leading a strike team
to take on more intense threats
cannonball stuck around becoming cable's
second in command
and the only original member of the new
mutants to make the transition to
x-force
it was also while he was on that
original roster that he died
when he was impaled through the gut by
sauron the mutant pterodactyl man energy
vampire
sam was only dead for a few minutes
before he came back to life
the reason behind his miraculous
resurrection well
it's complicated when you think about
the most powerful mutants in the marvel
universe
you probably think about the ones like
storm who can control the fundamental
forces of nature itself
or jean grey whose telekinesis can tap
into the world shattering power of the
phoenix
if you're up on your marvel comics
trivia you might even remember that
iceman was an omega level mutant
owing to his ability to create ice by
slowing down molecular motion
you probably don't think about the guy
from kentucky who can fly through the
air and crash
into stuff thanks to his exploding
bottom half and yet
here we are the reason that sam was able
to come back from the dead
at least according to cable is that he
may or may not be an external
if you're not familiar with the term
it's basically like being a mutant plus
incredibly powerful mutants who discover
at the moment of their first death that
they're actually immortals with eternal
lives that last around 12 000 years and
counting
the most well-known of the externals is
probably apocalypse
as for sam there's still some question
about whether he actually
is an external or not but considering
that he did spontaneously recover
after being impaled there's definitely
more going on
while he's not currently affiliated with
the x-men cannonball still has plenty of
team spirit
in fact when his old teammate sunspot
was looking to put together
a new team sam was one of the first
people he called see
while sunspot is mostly known for
channeling solar radiation into
incredible strength and explosive blast
of heat
he also has a power that was far more
effective in dealing with big problems
a staggeringly huge amount of money the
science terrorist organization aim
had been causing widespread destruction
in the marvel universe
since it was introduced in 1966 but
sunspot came up with a unique solution
to the problem
he bought the entire organization and
made a deal to work with shield and the
united states government
turning advanced idea mechanics into
american intelligence mechanics
and founding his own team of u.s
avengers the team was an odd one
with cannonball teaming up with squirrel
girl a mustachioed red hulk
a captain america from an alternate
future and a new version of the iron
patriot among others
a lot of superheroes come from a family
tree that's full of super powered
branches
and sam guthrie is no exception unlike a
lot of characters though
he was never tasked with carrying on the
heroic legacy of the previous generation
for the guthries becoming mutant heroes
at the xavier school was something that
was shared among siblings
the first of sam's nine siblings to take
up the life of a costumed adventurer was
his sister paige
who arrives to prominence in the pages
of generation x
as the name implies it was essentially
the mid-90s version of the same back to
school concept
that made new mutants a hit to begin
with with jubilee anchoring a cast of
even newer mutants
unlike most of her classmates however
paige wasn't entirely new
she'd first appeared about 10 years
earlier as part of sam's stereotypically
huge family
it wasn't until generation x though that
she was fully realized as a character
with the exception of jubilee who
anchored the team as its most
established member
the gen x kids all had interesting and
slightly gross powers and pages was
arguably the winner on both counts as
husk she could literally tear off her
own skin
to reveal the layer beneath it which
would change into whatever material she
chose
then once done she could tear off that
layer to revert to her normal form
or even a different material underneath
wow that's
so gross paige and sam weren't the only
guthries to seek higher education at the
xavier school
and sadly it didn't always end well
sam's little brother josh was introduced
way back in the new mutants
days in a story during which she was
initially terrified of developing mutant
abilities like his brother
and harboring a deep resentment towards
sam for abandoning his family to join
the new mutants
after going on an adventure with sam and
flying around on his brother's back
he decided that maybe being a mutant
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
of course at the time josh's only gift
as maguthry called it was his singing
voice
eventually he'd develop a slightly more
noticeable mutation
a pair of bright red wings that gave him
the code name icarus
as powers go that's pretty basic but it
would lead josh to tragedy
in 2006 new x-men embarked on one of the
darkest storylines in marvel history
the purifiers led by reverend william
striker
had been feuding on and off with the
x-men for a while and that year they
decided to go after the kids
a grand total of 42 former students were
killed
when the purifiers blew up a school bus
with more casualties to come
once they attacked the mansion the first
part of stryker's plan however was a bit
more insidious
he manipulated josh into cutting off his
own wings
then shot him dead as far as x-men
deaths go
it's one of the worst and certainly
among the most depressing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you